critics spend their lives telling you
which movies are good and which movies
are not so good but just because the
movies been savaged by critical
reception that doesn't actually mean
it's not worth your time
here are some surprisingly great but
critically hated movies you can watch on
Netflix right now national treasure home
is too
what
yes till the declaration independence
national treasure feels like someone
through Indiana Jones in a blender with
The Da Vinci Code and then added some
Nicolas Cage strangeness on top Cage
stars as the ridiculously named Benjamin
Franklin gates a treasure hunter who has
to decode a series of historical clues
that will lead him to a long buried
treasure hidden by the Freemasons
despite the high concept and a packed
cast of talented actors the film only
managed a 44% critic rating on Rotten
Tomatoes
despite that national treasure is a hoot
with laugh-out-loud dialogue and some
surprisingly accurate historical facts
well besides all the stuff about hidden
Freemason treasure that is on the back
of a hundred dollar bill was an etching
of Independence Hall based on a painting
done into thinking in the 1780s who in
this guy the artist was actually a
friend of Benjamin Franklin's it's a
wonderful mascots Christopher Guest has
been a part of some of the best comedy
films of the last 40 years from
best-in-show to this a spinal tap and
his faux documentary comedic stylings
are still hilarious today why don't you
just make 10 louder and make 10 be the
top number and make that a little louder
these count to 11 in short the man is a
comedy legend so it's no wonder that
2016's mascots his first feature-length
film in almost a decade came with some
high expectations the film follows a
group of sports mascots who gather for
the Fluffy's an annual competition and
awards ceremony for mascot tree
unfortunately the hype might have been
too much for the film as indicated by
its 50% Rotten Tomatoes rating while it
might not have delighted critics or even
most audiences the film's absolutely
worth a watch it's packed to the brim
with bizarre characters played by some
of the best comedic actors in the
business bronze Fluffy's silver fluffy
and gold fluffy and believe me every
mascot knows just how important those
awards can be wet hot American summer
some films become so ingrained in
popular culture that it's hard to
remember they weren't box-office smashes
or critical darlings when they came out
wet hot American summer is a perfect
example the cast list alone should
encourage you to see it it's led by a
roster of comedy all-stars that includes
Paul Rudd Ken Marino Amy Poehler
Bradley Cooper Elizabeth Banks H John
Benjamin and min
more
tastes like a burger
like you anymore unfortunately critics
couldn't quite click with the film
giving it a 33 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes still wet hot American summer
was ahead of its time and you should
absolutely check out this comedy classic
I'd like to take this opportunity to
thank you all for making the last eight
weeks without rival the best summer of
my entire life
Trailer Park Boys the movie an
adaptation of the long-running Canadian
comedy show of the same name Trailer
Park Boys the movie follows three
friends in a trailer park as they try to
get rich through petty crime the joy of
the show has always been about watching
the natural chemistry between the
characters and the movie extends that
simple pleasure beautifully
Julianne go Richie would be pursued by
the cops no not gonna happen
the movie is so great at creating a
sense of rhythm that you can't help but
relax into it despite its negative
critical reviews gyoon last of the
enforcers the original goon was a
surprisingly engaging sports movie with
a sweet romance and some genuinely great
acting from Sean William Scott in the
lead role
unfortunately the sequel goon last of
the enforcers didn't fare quite as well
critically only managing to muster 42%
at Rotten Tomatoes while it might not be
as electrifying as the first film last
of the enforcers is a capable sequel
bringing back fan favorite characters
and featuring even more grotesque
violence on the ice through it all Scott
anchors the film as the lovable
thick-headed Doug Glatt with the same
easy charisma and puppy-like enthusiasm
that he showed the first time out that's
when I got bit by the selling insurance
bug yep she laid eggs right inside of me
and now you're here I'm allergic to eggs
you're an idiot nobody's allergic to
eggs